the bullying is so bad it's so bad
this is why we can't have nice things
this is why more people aren't speaking up
because y'all take someone supporting a cause
to help children in a war torn country
and you make it about not supporting kids on the other side of the border
and I've gotten it too
and I knew I would
as soon as I started working for a crowdsourcing for Gofundme
for a Palestinian family
I knew people would say I didn't care about Israeli kids
and the reality is maybe I'm just like
a little bit naive
but I've been very outspoken about being a Jewish woman
having family in Israel
like the given is that I care
and I will post more stuff
but the humanitarian crisis
the lack of water
the lack of shelter
the lack of food
means that more people are gonna be giving attention to Gaza right now
and the bullying of people who speak out for the civilians on either side
either the hostages or the Gotham children
is insane no civilians deserve